so to kick things off with Gremlins what
is it that Drew you to this project
everything I was a massive fan of the
film massive fan of Stephen Spielberg
and uh just uh the fact that they're
taking a character that was very
mysterious and not
um really you know delved into the
character of Mr Wing and bringing them
uh bringing him back to tell his
backstory as a kid just brilliant yeah
so I know when I was growing up a lot of
media like this kind of kept the parents
to the side you know the kids never told
their parents what was going on but
Sam's parents played such a big role in
this story and I wonder was that
something that was like really important
to you in going into this backstory that
the parents are also such a part of it
yes and you know being a mom of two kids
like I want I I wanted to make sure that
um these two parents had a strong
influence on Sam
even though Sam was already so
independent you know he just he loved
his family he loved family life and um
and and the fact that uh uh they are not
a traditional type of uh you know
Chinese parents especially in the 1920s
back in Shanghai you know
um both uh Fong and Hong were a couple
that worked together that were equals
that respected each other I think those
are just all such positive
um uh role models for for kids and you
know and for families in general that uh
and and the fact that she is a massive
massive protector you know she's
fearless when it comes to taking care of
Sam are there aspects of yourself that
you kind of worked into the character as
this was being developed or did you
already feel such a like strong
connection to her I felt such a strong
connection to Fong you know
um she's a Chinese mom she loves to you
know try to have some control and when
she doesn't she panics but at the same
time
um she is willing to allow Sam to become
his own individual person and those are
all things that I want for my kids you
know that I want to be able to set
boundaries for them when they're younger
but then the ultimate goal is that
they're happy
when they're adults and and you know
pursue what they want what is something
you know no spoilers obviously but what
if something you would like to see from
the wings like in season two going
forward like just in kind of a
broader sense I guess I think it would
be great to find out
more about you know bongs like
um
if if grandpa has you know her dad has
these like special powers right yeah
there's some it's It's gotta have been
passed down so I I think there's a
reason why she got into Chinese medicine
I think there's a reason why she's as
smart as she is and uh and I would love
to have um you know Fong and Hong I have
more scenes together too because I love
BD and uh uh it's just always so great
you know we've had this chemistry all
these years and it would just be fun to
continue to explore and play with these
characters with BD Wong I know sometimes
with animation like sometimes you're
recording on your own sometimes you're
recording together did you and B to get
Court together at all or was it all
I don't know we had to work separately
because uh it was during covid right the
that time so um and he lives in New York
and I live in LA but I think uh we just
you know we can hear each other at this
point yeah you know after two decades
over two decades so there's just this
innate chemistry that we have with this
with each other it's a pivoting for just
a second I have to ask about Star Wars
because I'm a huge fan of yours I'm a
huge fan of fenikshand
um when I got to speak to tomorrow
Morrison last year I sort of asked him
in his head like what the continued
Adventures of boba and fennec would look
like so I want to ask you the same thing
like if you got to continue that story
what what does that look like to you I
would like to see what they do with
their
um
um their you know their uh what's the
word like you know he he's this uh Lord
now of uh tantooine right and he is
managing
to have some control
um but he was trying to do it one way
and I'm not sure how effective it was so
because he was trying to have a greater
honor System and I would love to see
that he turns back to a bit more like
what Boba Fett was in also being able to
maintain Justice or or accomplish what
he needs to accomplish
um on Tatooine but um and then
ultimately just to have a lot of fun
battle scenes so bringing it back to
Gremlin then what is something you hope
both fans of the original movie and then
now new fans will be able to take away
from the show with Gremlins oh gosh
um just the fact that you know
the original Gremlins had
one particular storyline about the
Chinese mukwise and now with this
Gremlins in secrets of Mogwai you get to
explore the Chinese culture more you get
to explore the Chinese history in
Shanghai in 1920s you get to see other
types of folklores and fairy tale
characters that I grew up with and to be
able to share that
um you know and everything from the even
the Chinese medicines to
um the magic that I grew up it's just a
sort of like a mix of you know our Harry
otter with Grims fairy tales with yeah
and and those were scary fairy tales we
grew up with the same I think it was a
way to like teach kids and
scare them a bit but the great thing is
because we still have Joe Dante and
Steven Spielberg behind it
um it maintains that fresh sort of
energetic shock value that the original
film had and yet super family friendly
so
I'm I'm looking forward to seeing the
reactions you mentioned having grown up
with these stories was like were any of
your favorites touched on or is that
something maybe down the line yeah I
mean I don't know what I can talk about
but definitely there were many many
characters like oh I saw those in the
movie back when I was a kid you know
with my mom and I'm like I don't know
why my mom took me to those scary movies
I don't think she uh she worried about
it very much
like I still remember to this day that
scared me for a long time there was this
like like ghost or something that came
out of the toilet
that was the kind of thing when I was
younger
oh man well thank you so much
congratulations on the show it was
lovely to speak with you
you yeah I hope everyone enjoys it it's
it's such a great animation